[Music]
on this Thursday night ottawa's fall
fiscal update is there relief on the way
for the High Cost of Living I know that
it has felt like just one thing after
another I'll ask the Finance Minister if
avoiding a recession is possible grocery
Giants accused of being greedy the
rapidly Rising profits at Soaring prices
eat away at Shoppers wallets
spiteful testimony from a convoy leader
little Mr Trudeau there in his boxing
shorts with his Juice Box the latest
tents exchanges at the emergencies act
inquiry and an American doctor's mission
to help women seeking abortions and the
danger he faces I thought that I would
be assassinated
foreign
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
every country in the world is worrying
about its economic future right now and
today Canada's Finance Minister and
Deputy Prime Minister outlined what she
intends to do to help Canadians
Christopher Freeland delivered a mini
budget called a fall economic statement
and said tough times are ahead
it's important as both the Deputy Prime
Minister and the Minister of Finance
that I'm honest with Canadians about the
challenges that still lie ahead interest
rates are rising as the Bank of Canada
steps in to tackle inflation and that
means our economy is slowing down
it means there are people whose mortgage
payments are rising
Chief political correspondent David
Aiken is with me David we know all those
things are true and Freeland talked
about helping Canadians who can't pay
their bills and growing the economy at
the same time neither are easy in this
climate how is the government saying it
can do it well Donna inflation the cost
of living is you know clearly top of
mind for most Canadians and it is the
top priority for the federal government
and that's where I want to start with
the High Cost of Living so many of us so
many Canadians are concerned about it
but despite the concern this fall
economic statement is thin on new ways
to help the government will tweak the
payment schedule of the Canada workers
benefit it's a benefit paid to about 3
million Canadians worth about fourteen
hundred dollars a year for single
workers and twenty five hundred dollars
a year for households it will now be
paid out in quarterly installments
rather than once a year at tax time the
government is also moving to permanently
eliminate interest on federal student
and Apprentice loans but that's about it
the government's kept a lot of its
powder dry to be able to make stronger
moves in a number of areas that they've
signaled in this fiscal update in fact
one of the biggest things the government
is doing to fight inflation is not
making it worse with huge new spending
programs we really don't want to make
the central banks job harder we don't
want to to put the Bank of Canada in a
position where it has to raise rates
higher it would take an awful lot of
money to kind of move that economy and
and to be inflationary so this really
shouldn't be contributing the government
also acknowledges economic growth will
slow to a crawl next year though it
thinks Canada will avoid a recession
that said a senior government official
said if there is a recession in this
country it will be quote shallow and
short as to the fiscal bottom line well
it's improving when the government
tabled the budget last spring it thought
the deficit this year would be about 53
billion dollars but the economy has been
doing better than anticipated giving
Ottawa a windfall of about 30 billion
dollars now some of that will be used to
pay for things like doubling the GST tax
credit but about half of that windfall
will go to reducing this year's deficit
now expected to clock in at about 36
billion dollars
speaking of deficits this is the first
time the Trudeau government has tabled
any budget document since it was elected
in 2015 that shows a balanced budget
somewhere down the road that's right the
Trudeau government says it will balance
the budget but not until
2028. Donna okay David Aiken in Ottawa
thanks I'll talk to Christopher Freeland
a little bit later in the newscast but
first we know costs are soaring for just
about everything and food prices are
rising at the fastest rate in 40 years
now new research shows Canada's three
biggest chains posted higher profits
this year compared with their average
performances over the last five years
and one company in particular really
stands out Nito Garcia digs into the
numbers and how the companies are
responding
customers at this Independent Grocer in
BC are searching for deals on produce
there's lots of small independent green
Grocers especially you can get really
good produce at a much fairer price
while food prices are rising at the
fastest rate in more than four decades
major grocery chains are being accused
of price gouging and so-called greed
flation new research suggests the
country's top three Grocers saw higher
profits this year compared to their
average performances over the last five
years and Loblaws is outperforming its
best gross profit over that same period
by 180 million dollars over the last six
months Loblaws has generated a million
dollars per day more than their record
year which is which is quite a bit and
so it begs the question whether or not
these profits are coming from food sales
or sales from other departments this
Canadian researcher says a key issue is
a lack of transparency highlighting a
need for companies to make their
financial results more accessible in the
Canadian territories it's a different
picture one of the few grocery retailers
there North West CO and the biggest
beneficiary of the federal Northern food
program saw a reduction in sales but an
increase in profits in the past year in
2020 it's on 82 percent rise in profits
the government should probably be
stepping in and
taking some measures some places it
seems like it's yeah the profit margin
is quite High
um but if we were regulate it you know
that would make a big difference the
rising cost of food has prompted the
competition Bureau of Canada to study
the industry as Grocers defend their
profits saying margins haven't changed
Global News
a dire warning from the bank of England
today not only are interest rates
jumping up the UK is facing its longest
recession since record-keeping began the
bank raised its base interest rate from
2.25 to 3 percent that is the biggest
jump since 1989 and it pushes borrowing
costs to their highest rate since 2008.
the governor of the bank of England also
says there's a tough road ahead for
households he says the recession could
last two years and the unemployment rate
is forecast to nearly double by 2025.
more of the people who claim to be in
charge of the so-called Freedom Convoy
earlier this year testified at the
inquiry into the use of the federal
emergencies act including a man who
wanted to peacefully overthrow the
government what's becoming clear is how
chaotic and divided the people who call
themselves organizers of the protests
really were it was also revealed today
how the movement was able to raise
millions of dollars in funding Abigail
Beeman reports
when we see our government completely
violating all the laws I understand
there's where do we turn to the Senate
is our last hope James Bater pushed back
on the idea that his now Infamous mou
aim to overthrow the government even
though it lists the unelected Senate and
governor general as representing itself
as the government of Canada as a whole
in a push to get rid of mandates and
under oath he accused the actual
government of treason we wanted to sit
down with the Senate and say here you
know we we believe our government is
committing treason uh enforce the laws
please
cross-examination by lawyers highlighted
botter's tendency towards conspiracy and
you've shared on that Facebook hashtags
for Q Anon
there yeah so and um that 911 was
planned by a shadowy uh government body
and hateful comments this is an alpha
meal uh trucker oil Patch Farm Boy kind
of guy uh and see an old little Mr
Trudeau there in his boxing shorts with
his Juice Box water bottle sort of
things yeah
we call him Justine the commission also
heard about infighting and Discord
between various Convoy leaders BJ Victor
said he dismissed voter and the mou it
was a joke and didn't mince words about
Jeremy McKenzie who testifies Friday he
makes Mel Gibson look like a rabbi
uh he is really really aggressive
towards Jews the commission also learned
about how much money rolled in and from
where in total donors raised 24 million
dollars to support the Convoy 10 million
through GoFundMe 1.2 million through
Bitcoin and almost 12 and a half million
through give send go with nearly half
that amount donated by Americans I felt
that some people didn't see me
they just saw 10 million dollars over my
head Tamara Leach launched the GoFundMe
money first went to a TD account in her
name she learned funds were frozen when
trying to pay for a charter flight to
bring Convoy lawyers and others
including her husband to Ottawa did you
consult with the finance committee
before attempting to use the money for
that purpose I don't believe I did do
you know why most of the Convoy money
since returned to donors Millions still
held in escrow Abigail Beeman Global
News
Ottawa
one-on-one with Canada's Finance
Minister coming up I asked Christian
Freeland about ottawa's fall fiscal
update and whether avoiding a recession
is possible
we know Canadians are struggling to keep
up with their bills and with me from
Ottawa now is federal Finance Minister
and Deputy Prime Minister Christia
Freeland who delivered a fall fiscal
update earlier today Ms Freeland thanks
for taking time for us you know
economists have warned that a recession
is coming you're projecting two
scenarios a soft landing and a hard
Landing I know there is a lot of
uncertainty but what will it take to hit
that soft landing and avoid a recession
well let me just say one thing Donna on
our base base scenario which is the soft
Landing scenario and I know you know
this very well but Canada has this great
track to keep all the politics out of
our budget process so that space case
scenario is not written by me or by the
brilliant eponymous here in the
Department of Finance it's the average
of private sector Economist we surveyed
in September so that entirely objective
that's what the private sector was
selling at now you're right we also have
a downside scenario because as you have
pointed out some people have become a
little more pessimistic and and we
thought it was important transparent
with Canadians about that and also
frankly to show them that we stress
tested the federal finances and we can
show you that even if things get a
little worse
Canada is going to be
I know you've said you can't compensate
every Canadian struggling with the
rising cost of living but people do want
some solutions is what is in this mini
budget enough
uh there are a lot of Solutions in this
fall economic statement which we make a
lot of different for a lot of people and
I want to highlight one thing that is
maybe the most important for me that I
announced today and that is that Morrow
our GS secret is going to give nearly
500 the Canadian families needed the
most that is going to start arriving
tomorrow in people's bank accounts in
their mailbox that goes to 11 million
Canadian households that's going to make
a difference right now when people
really need you talk today about keeping
Canada's fiscal powder dry what does
that actually mean and what are you
reserving it for
um Donna that is a great question and
what that means is that we get it we get
that now is a really worrying time for a
lot of Canadians and it is
understandable that people would be
worried we had two and a half years of
covid who could have imagined that and
things think change every month and then
we had this horrible thing of cooking
invading Ukraine and now we have
inflation something we haven't
experienced in a generation and people
are talking about how maybe the global
economy is going to get even
so I think a lot of Canadians are really
anxious and when I say we're keeping our
fiscal fire powder dry what I mean is
Canada is on the federal government has
the resources to support Canadians come
what may and I really hope and believe
that Canadians should make a lot of
reassurance
okay quick answer to this one if you
could in the spring you imposed a one a
one-time windfall tax on Banks and
insurance company profits now oil and
gas companies are making record profits
President Biden calls it War
profiteering shell CEO said today he's
willing to pay higher taxes the NDP are
calling for it what's stopping you
well I think we have done a smart thing
when it comes to corporate taxation in
this fall economic State and that is to
introduce an app on share buyback if
that two percent
and what that is going to do is it's
going to raise a meaningful amount of
money more than two billion dollars over
five years
but also it is creating the right
incentive for Canadian companies and
what that tax says is if you have enough
money to buy back their shares how about
instead of buying back their shares you
invest that money in your company in
your productivity you invest that money
in your workbook so I think that is a
smart way to go if the way to encourage
something we really need which is
companies be investing more in Canada
companies to be investing more in
Canadian work
all right Christopher Freeland Deputy
Prime Minister Finance Minister thanks
No Deal ahead mediation with Ontario
education workers ends what it means for
students
[Music]
talks have now broken down between the
Ontario government and the union
representing the province's education
workers the education Minister says his
government is going ahead with with
legislation to impose a contract and ban
a strike the union says its members
intend to walk off the job tomorrow
Colin Demello joins me from Queens Park
in Toronto Colin is there any room to
maneuver now or is this strike
inevitable
the strike is an inevitable the
negotiations have concluded the
mediators dismiss the two sides Donna
feeling that they were too far apart and
there would not be a deal and so the
Ford government
resorted to an extraordinary measure
they imposed the notwithstanding Clause
imposing a contract on 55 000 education
support workers they are retaliating
they announced that they will be going
on strike regardless beginning tomorrow
and they haven't really given us a
deadline for when they would return to
the job they say the strike as of now is
indefinite which means the parents of 2
million children are now just holding
their Collective breath waiting for news
on when this will all end and how and
Colin what did the education Minister
say today about the repercussions
against the workers who do strike
well baked into this legislation that
imposes this contract are stiff fines
for any QP member that decides to walk
off the job four thousand dollars per
individual per day and the union could
face a fine of a daily five hundred
thousand dollars for every day that
they're off the job the education
Minister says this is an illegal strike
and he intends to enforce it using those
tools using those very Hefty fines
although behind the scenes Donna the
premier staff tell me that he doesn't
want to necessarily use those fines on
the front line workers because it would
run contrary to Premier Doug Ford's
brand which is sticking up for the
little guy just as the Ford government
here uses the notwithstanding Clause to
impose a contract never before seen in
this province on the little guy all
right lots to watch for on the story
Colin Demello in Toronto for now thanks
it's providing high-risk care next the
American abortion Doctor Who puts his
life on the line to help patients
[Music]
abortion has emerged as a big issue in
the upcoming midterm elections in the
U.S that was expected after the U.S
Supreme Court overturned Roe versus Wade
Landmark ruling that made abortion legal
in 1973 for patients and doctors though
it's much more than political it is
deeply personal in both Canada and the
U.S 90 percent of abortions take place
in the first trimester but in the U.S
now that access has been reduced some
women have no choice but to wait longer
pharah Nasser spoke to one of the few
doctors performing high risk late-term
abortions
for 50 years Dr Warren Hearn has made it
his life's work to provide access to
abortion it's my work that's what I do
and I'm committed to doing it I have
been for a long time Dr Hearn runs this
clinic in Boulder Colorado one of very
few specializing in the most difficult
and sensitive areas women in need of
late abortions
here on intake day these seats will be
filled with women in exceptional
circumstances a very large proportion of
my patients have fetal abnormalities
with a desired pregnancy they don't want
to have an abortion they want to have a
baby or their own medical problem that
threatens their life we have somebody
who's living in her car with her
children who can't afford to have
another child his dedication to women's
Reproductive Rights began before
abortion was even legal I was struck by
the desperation of the women during that
time there was a woman who went to
Denver General Hospital to have an
abortion and they wouldn't help her she
went home and shot herself in the uterus
and then drove herself to the hospital
since then he's treated some of the most
vulnerable on a typical week a third of
my patients are adolescents at the age
of 13 14 15 years old
and some of them raped yeah
by a family member or somebody else Dr
Hearn has seen patients as young as 10
years old and he's watched abortion laws
come full circle in a landmark ruling
the Supreme Court today legalized
abortions I was there on December the
13th 1971 when Sarah Weddington argued
the Roe versus Wade case for the first
time this has affected the lives of tens
of millions of women in this country
for the worse how important are these
midterm elections critical the plan
since 1973 to overturn Roe versus Wade
and the Republican process the politics
have been designed for that and they
achieved their objective many women who
come in to see us have very unusual and
difficult circumstances some of them now
are not able to get early abortions
because the Republicans have shut down
the abortion clinics all over the
country and in
to work at Great risk I can't go out the
front door when the anti-abortion
demonstrators are out there because I
have to assume that they're carrying
weapons and they'll kill me they have a
chance in order to even get access
Clinic you have to go through one
two
three
four secure and bulletproof doors plus
24 7 security camera surveillance you
bought the other building for security
yeah
because I didn't want a gun pointed at
me from one of the offices you're 84
years old yeah how long are you going to
keep doing this
I don't know long as I can closing the
door to a peaceful retirement and
continuing a life of service to Women in
Need Farah Nasser Global News Boulder
Colorado
that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your Canada is on away Centennial Park
in Onaway Alberta we'd love to see your
Canada please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com and thanks for
watching Fara Nasser will be at the
anchor desk tomorrow I'll see you
Saturday for the new reality and next
week from Washington D.C bye-bye
foreign
[Music]